i'm doing some surveillance on a
slaughter farm
miami florida on this farm they're
killing the sledgehammers
and butchering
i think alive lot of them saw me on a
they patrol this area
on atvs
threats have been made for the past 13
years
on my life
not too popular in these areas when they
weren't chasing me with sledgehammers
and axes
i would be getting phone calls i would
be getting emails i would be getting
messages on social media
an undercover operation sheds light into
the cruel treatment of animals
at a west palm beach farm the animals
behind us
residing in this torture operation had a
voice today
when people would be arrested in
interrogation rooms they would tell law
enforcement
that guy kudo had better watch his ass
because there are bounties
on this guy's head he's the only one
taking this industry down
and no one wants that person breathing
[Music]
anymore
so richard kudo is an interesting guy to
say the least
so right now we are in area 97 and
we're just going over some mappings of
some slaughter farms and animal fighting
farms
he sailed on the americas cup team like
extreme sports guy
he was also a property flipper in miami
in south beach in the 2000s when the
market was quite hot
and it's where i blossomed financially
it's where i made my money and made my
nest egg
but i had a void i had a void
of doing something more important with
my life
so cuda was volunteering with the spca
back in 2008
basically mucking stalls doing whatever
work they needed around
the barn and they got a distress call
one day
uh from the police because spca would
often help relocate
you know animals that the police would
find in distress
so you know i went out there driving my
range rover
you know leaving south beach and they
came across
at a sort of butcher's farm that the
police were at they came across this
horse beautiful horse brown with white
on its nose
in a broken leg he was emaciated
and i walked up to him and he put his
head in my arms and he just put all his
weight on me
and right then and there i started
falling for this animal
but underneath the horse's lip on its
gums was tattooed
a code and they were
kind of curious to know what that meant
turns out that resources are tattooed on
their lips to
show where they're from and what their
pedigree is and they belong to
and so this horse this horse is named
freedom's flight
uh the the horse had broken its leg
during a race
so i tracked his lineage and
it was shocking that i learned of his
bloodlines that it came from some of the
more famous racehorses on the planet
how could this horse end up at an
illegal slaughterhouse
it boggled my mind
he ended up adopting him freedom's
flight still lives at his compound in
florida
um sort of got him going into this world
of
underground horse butchering
[Music]
these are slaughter horses here and we
have a mare down here
she's clinging to life right now the
spca
was not an organization that was geared
towards me or anyone else going
undercover
and investigating these people which is
the only reason why i
started the animal recovery mission the
animal recovery mission taped and
exposed the property while conducting
an investigation we basically go on to
cover
where no one else will
[Music]
in the public sector in the private
sector if they're disregarding something
as far as animal cruelty
arm will take it on it's
something that is so incredibly
important
and it's become my life's mission oh he
is so skinny
i would just cut checks and rip out you
know
my bank accounts to uh to fund it
without thinking about it
the guy right here and his wife who
started farm
and to be honest i don't know how much
money that i've spent
but it's close to the seven figures over
and it's it's been worth it
i'm dealing with the usda right now um
on a horse meat by i've basically been
embedded with some horse killers
so horse meat internationally is a
pretty commonly
eaten food not on the level of beef or
pork
but it's popular in a lot of cultures in
japan central asia
france and in cuba and a lot of cuban
americans live in south florida
and many of them still want to eat horse
meat
they're eating horse meat for medical
purposes they think that it cures
blood disorders that it helps with side
effects from chemotherapy
but all horse meat whether it's imported
or horses are slaughtered and butchered
in this country for human consumption
it's illegal
this is roughly 30 pounds of horse meat
purchased in
palm beach county they've actually cut
this horse meat
into small steak like fillets
in florida the problem is that many
times
laws geared towards protecting animals
are not being upheld by law enforcement
prosecutors judges and juries and that's
extremely
extremely frustrating the laws in
florida
are still too weak if you are a
first-time felony animal abuser
it is unlikely that you will get prison
time
you may get county jail time
but that even would be in some cases a
stretch
there's really not a whole lot i can do
with them
either they plead guilty or they're
found guilty
because most judges even in the most
horrible crimes
do not put them in jail will not put
them in prison
so they're placed on probation
animal abuse here is so underreported
because they're simply
are not the resources for the police
departments
the sheriff's department animal care and
control to go
out and really investigate these crimes
so right now i'm in the c9 basin and i
just arrived to a really nasty property
with
four completely emaciated horses
[Music]
the c9 basin is this patch of brushy
land wedged between miami and the
everglades
and it's really meant to be an
ecological buffer zone it's not really
meant to have
humans living there um but lots of
people do live there
here are the horses this is the kill
area here
that's the rug that they're covering the
horses with after they remove the meat
when i first started investigating the
basin at the beginning of 2009
law enforcement wouldn't even go into
the basin no one would go into the basin
and uphold laws certainly wouldn't go in
there to investigate
crimes against animals which was why
horsemeat was flourishing as an industry
this area is pretty lawless a local
paper
in miami called it the closest thing
america has to a wild west outpost and
having been there a couple times i can
attest to that being true
[Music]
and then people's pet horses start being
stolen
usually someone's pet horse their pony
they'll come to the barn in the morning
and either the horse's toe is vanished
or you know a couple hundred yards away
and a trail of blood away there's a
perfectly butchered and filleted carcass
of what used to be your pet pony
not only was my horse stolen he was
butchered
he was tied up to a palm tree so all
these are blood stains here yeah
when i started going in to the basin
in 2009 i was still a developer
but i knew hundreds of thousands of
animals were in there being brutalized
with everyone ignoring the crimes
against them
uh animals were killed and really in
humane ways you know being stabbed in
the chest or shot with low caliber guns
their throat slit being tortured boiled
alive really horrific stuff
and to see his videos you know he has a
massive trove of undercover videos
is pretty scary stuff this is kudo with
arm
i am investigating an illegal slaughter
farm
i didn't know what i was doing
completely and utterly untrained
i am armed but i still don't
feel that safe
and i started to infiltrate properties
some of them legally some of them
illegally and i started to document
the crimes against the animals you see a
horse
doesn't look like he's in great shape
before he got involved there really
wasn't a lot of
policing of this world the police down
there
have a lot on their plates in terms of
murder and robbery and
credit card fraud and so animal cruelty
was not really high on their list of
priorities
i think that when you have a state where
animal cruelty
is way too prevalent and our laws are
way too weak
it's important to have someone like
richard kudo out there
he's someone who's a true believer who
takes risks
and sometimes crosses the line to get
these
secret videos out to the public
i understand his passion
behind it but the
way he goes about it is not the way one
should go about it if you're going to
successfully prosecute
these animal cruelty cases i
investigated the c9 basin for roughly
six months
and i comprised files of roughly 100
properties
illegal properties and i presented it to
law enforcement
but i also collected violations building
violations zoning violations
um environmental violations while i was
collecting crimes against animals so i'm
just coming out of this waterfall now
and after roughly six months of
just about every night infiltrating
every single property that i possibly
could in the basin
i created a report and the police
they're shocked by what's going on in
the basin but not only from an animal
rights perspective
but also from a zoning and codes
perspective
and the investigation of the c9 basin
actually led to operation restore
and it was one of the largest operations
in history of the state of florida
thousands of agents
tactically hitting the entire c9 basin
just after dawn an army of regulators
and police deployed
to shut down slaughter farms it was just
a massive takedown
of illegal activity that was going on in
the c9 basin
you know 17 cockfighting rings over 400
illegal structures hundreds of citations
issued for dumping and butchering and
animal cruelty
it was the most incredible thing that i
had ever seen
and all of those nights infiltrating
these properties
all of those nights being chased with
machetes and axes
the danger that i put myself in um
it paid off so after the raid
governor charlie crest signs a law that
basically
increases penalties for slaughtering
forces
and to kudo this seems like it should be
you know the end of the story is sort of
climax and it's actually the end of act
one
in this story
so kudo is on a high uh
you know you can almost hear the the
happy music playing
as he's awarded citizen of the year by
the miami new times
but he starts becoming more paranoid
about the enemies that he's making
butchers do not like him they have
followed him they have shot at him
kill buyers people all over the country
who are buying courses to export for me
don't like him and so his paranoia was
actually quite justified
all these mofos know who i am and what i
look like and they
don't like me
there was one year i believe i moved
close to seven different times
because they were finding my address in
utilities
when i would put my name under an
electric bill
or a cable bill the police and the local
authorities
were kind of like all right we made some
arrests we did some enforcement
let's move on to other topics uh whereas
he wasn't able to let it go
i wasn't looking in the past in my
accomplishments i was looking at the
future
of what still needed to be done so after
the raid
he begins fundraising quite aggressively
and
in addition to being very good at
garnering media attention he's very good
at
opening people's wallets and he goes
from 100 000 to 200 000 to 500 thousand
to you know several million dollars a
year
in annual uh income from from donations
undercover video of animal cruelty
captured at a popular farm in northwest
indiana is under review
he starts doing undercover operations in
indiana and and
other states abroad in asia looking at
animal cruelty there
greetings from bangladesh um and the
vision is that
from the springboard of the c9 basin he
will catapults into
you know much larger operations but what
he doesn't realize is that the c9 basin
story is not finished at all
we went to the c9 basin at christmas
time two years ago
and we saw a blacked out fence
and heard animals screaming and knew
that that was an illegal slaughterhouse
so we walked in and sure enough
they were butchering every animal you
could imagine alive
goats sheep pigs birds
so we started to buy pigs and goats for
meat for human consumption
then we started purchasing horse meat
and this took
back and forth we're talking two years
this is a long
investigation called operation genesis
they start building a case file against
the owner of
of the farm oh yeah there it is
it's a little chop it up put in these
bags
and in november 2020 kudo invited me
down
to florida to be part of the raid on the
slaughterhouse
last night the department of health
announced that there are two presumptive
positive cases
of coronavirus disease in the state of
florida
so the pandemic hit in march uh
about a week after i was in south
florida with kudo
and this really put a hamper on his
plans i had to
pull my investigators out of the field
months and months later
we went back and forth with emails with
law enforcement and i got a very bad
feeling
that law enforcement did not want this
case for some reason
the plan was basically kind of a hail
mary they were going to go undercover
that morning bring some evidence out and
then call 9-1-1
we called 9-1-1 law enforcement
responded
and gave excuses on why they couldn't
make arrests
the police immediately knew who kudo was
you could see
how annoyed they were at him and you
could see that they really didn't want
to be there
so they wrote up you know some notes
they opened a case file and they
basically told us to get lost
when it's disregarded you throw up your
hands you you let out a sigh
you're you're so disheartened you
question
your tactics should i have brought this
case to law enforcement to begin with
i think someone who's out there to hold
accountable the worst
of the animal abusers is a good thing
it's just that sometimes we can't use
his evidence because it doesn't meet the
standards of admissibility in a
courtroom
you cannot just go in and film people
and record people we do have laws on
that
no matter what you see what you hear
you cannot as a private citizen film
people
record people without their consent in
the state of florida
and you cannot continually go in
and have them slaughter an animal in
front of you just so you can film what
they're doing
over the years of the last decade their
patience has worn increasingly thin
to the point where now you know they
they want they say they want to work
with them
but they give very little uh indication
that that's
that's actually true it seems like they
really would like him to to go away
you question everything about yourself
about your organization
are you really making an impact are you
really helping animals
[Music]
i created arm to create change
no matter what i'm not here to make
friends with prosecutors
or law enforcement or anyone else i'm
here to help animals
and that's it that's the difference
between being an activist and a
prosecutor you know being an activist is
to make a point
and being a prosecutor is to do justice
and you can only do justice within
the confines of the courtroom with rules
of evidence
so i guess you have to ask yourself do
you want to make a point or do you want
to make a difference
working with law enforcement in
government has very little meaning to me
my main goal at arm now is to educate
at times even change diets because if
people didn't eat meat
then there wouldn't be these markets for
me to investigate
they would not exist i will never
ever give up i'll strive to make change
and to help animals and live a good
decent ethical life for them
you